we're not even close to the third
college football weekend and usc fired
clay hilton yesterday
and a man who's been all over this story
his athletic article that uh was posted
on twitter
in relation to all this usc's next
football coach bruce feldman's
candidates to watch including a pac-12
foe
is on the athletic.com and also you can
hit the link on his twitter feed at
bruce feldman bruce feldman of fox
sports in the athletic back here in the
rich eyes and show hari bruce
good morning rich good to talk some
football same to you let's start with
the obvious question why and why now
what do you got for me on that all right
so look clay holden has been on the hot
seat at ufc really since about
2018. that's a long time recruiting has
suffered and they gave him every
opportunity i think they have the new
relatively new athletic director mike
bone had uh
kind of
really gave him uh more support more
infrastructure and and they thought
they'd reshape his staff but the reality
is
the problem is still
the product on the field and
they got blown out they got embarrassed
on saturday night at the coliseum by a
stanford team that got whooped the week
before by k-state uh yet fans block into
the exits from what i'm told mike bone
the a.d was
disheartened borderline disgusted by
what he saw as well and i think
come sunday
he realized it's not a matter of of if
it's a matter of when and the timetable
they looked at was well you know what we
have we're on the road this week against
a bad washington state team then we have
a pretty mediocre oregon state team
coming back to the coliseum and probably
none of our fans are gonna come show up
uh i think they felt like this move
they just realized because the fans had
already realized it clay hulk was not
going to be able to lead them to the
playoff the team was just under
achieving
and they were not happy with the product
it's just that simple they
to me from everything i've heard it has
been a a monday through friday kind of
problem they do not practice with the
physicality or the intensity
or have the organization
to really develop players and develop
this team the way other top programs do
and
i think it was
it was enough they finally said we gotta
just rip the band-aid off
so um
they did and is this just also the
the timing also have to do with the fact
that the the contract that lin swan
bestowed on helton as an extension a
couple of years ago has finally reached
a point where they're willing to eat it
what's remaining on it is that it yeah
pretty much it's somewhat manageable now
in terms of what he it's a 10 million
dollar balloon that they're gonna have
to pop as opposed to a couple of years
ago when he was really on the hot seat
um they were looking at to get rid of
him to get rid of the staff than to
bring somebody else in somewhere close
to 50 million dollars that they would
have had to be on the hook for
um now what's interesting is
a couple of years ago a lot of the fans
were really clamoring for urban meyer he
was out of coaching at that point doing
tv
and
the the realities from what i understand
from people i trust that careful the new
president who had taken over at usc at
the time was dealing with all sorts of
scam well i'm not sure about athletic
department-wise i'm talking about
university-wise ufc was engulfed in it
and the idea of hiring urban meyer who
has baggage especially
not that far removed from that zack
smith scandal where urban
uh got suspended for three games i don't
think he was even somebody they could
consider uh she wanted anything to do
with so that was an unwieldy search
process for them this is more manageable
and it's going to be interesting to see
who they target and who is going to want
to come up you know let's say come
across the country i'm giving away kind
of where i think this may go but who's
going to want to come across the country
and potentially take over a usc program
that has really been spinning its wheels
for a while bruce feldman from the
athletic and fox sports here on the rich
eisen show okay the who next in usc
walk me through your thought process and
who might be on the radar screen of a
former cincinnati athletic director and
what might be informing his decision um
to replace clay hilton
yeah i mean an obvious choice would be
the guy he hired at cincinnati luke
fickle he's done a really good job there
they have a top 10 team again
i am not convinced luke fickle
will
want to come he has six kids i'm not
convinced he will want to move that
family to southern california
and
everything i've heard is luke fickle has
a strong midwestern roots obviously a
terrific player at ohio state i don't
think the ohio state job is coming open
anytime soon and i had heard
he had he might potentially have some
interest in notre dame down the road but
that job's probably not coming open now
if the penn state job came open would he
be interested in that who knows but you
know now with the news that cincinnati
is joining the big 12 that came up last
week
that job has gotten more attractive
maybe he doesn't need to leave
so i'm not sure that he would be
he's going to be the answer another guy
in the midwest also an ohio guy who's
done a terrific job and the name nfl
fans know know a little bit is matt
campbell from iowa state terrific coach
has really built that program they had
their best season ever last year
finishing number nine
um
that to me might be a little
uh
more
i don't say better fit but i i would be
less surprised if he were to make the
move now again
it he's had opportunities his nfl teams
are interested in him and so he's turned
down some good things because he really
likes what he has there so i don't think
it's gonna i think it's gonna take a lot
to get him to leave ames iowa and then
the third guy i would say to really keep
an eye on
you know from that part of the country
is james franklin the penn state head
coach did a great job at vandy
he's done really well at penn state he's
been there a long time rich i mean now
and i'm not saying he's getting stale
there or anything but he has been there
for a long time you could see anybody
who knows james ryan could see his
personality resonating really well
in los angeles at usc i think that would
play well
um he's just got a big presence to him
he is recruited at an extra
exceptionally high level
so
again he's the guy i could see
usc being very interested in and i could
see at the end of the day him having a
lot to think about with it the kind of a
wild card guy to keep an eye on
is is mario cristobal he's in the same
same conference he's at oregon just had
a huge win where they whipped ohio state
in columbus
he's recruited in southern california
really well he's got a great situation
and i know
he thinks he has a
a team that has a chance to win national
titles in the next two years on what
he's built
so
you know would he be tempted to leave i
think that's a call that usc
may want to at least kick the tires off
so you want to let's let's let's get
some real talk here uh bruce bruce
feldman the athletic and and fox sports
what what what does usc have going for i
mean you know like
there are no sacred cows anymore there
there really are not anymore you're
seeing it in the nba you're seeing it in
all sorts of sports you're seeing the
historic alliance needing to be formed
because of what's down the road with the
sec and what they're all cooking up um
what what does usc have going for it
other than the fact that that's where
some great people used to play i'm being
honest it's got three big things going
for it i think make it unique the first
one is there is an insane amount of
talent within a two-hour drive of los
angeles
that is not insignificant
now mario cristobal has done well
recruiting in southern california coming
from
from eugene oregon where there's just
not the same level of talent or nowhere
close to it
but it has helped because you had the
coach at usc being basically uh what
feels like a lame duck coach for three
years that has made a lot easier for
people to recruit talent out of here it
wasn't so easy when pete carroll had it
going it honestly wasn't even that easy
when elaine kiffin came in after him so
that's one thing the other thing is
no no power five school is better
positioned compared to the rest of its
league to be a top dog then usc is in
the pac-12 especially in the pac-12
south it has different resources it has
it has different tradition it has a such
a recruiting base if you're at your own
for your alma mater if you're at james
franklin school of penn state you still
got ohio state in your in your division
you know even if you're at alabama you
got lsu you got texas a m you got
georgia right there not far away you got
florida that's a lot of other
heavyweights to compete with
you know what mario cristobal has done
with oregon and certainly they had a ton
of success when chip kelly was there and
then when mark helfrich you know
followed up that but
it's still not quite the same dynamic so
there's that and then there is that
element of of what you're talking about
the great history they have and it's
been a while since they've been great
but
a lot of kids and their families grew up
wanting to be trojans and i think it's
hard it's easier to ignite that spark
when you have that kind of connection if
it's the right head coach there
and so i think people look at that and
they see and also the facilities have
been upgraded significantly since the
days when pete carroll was was there
when they had stuff still kind of
outdated from the late 60s
what about urban
you're already hearing the rumors and
you're already seeing you know like
bobby petrino's name getting thrown
around and that's a reason why urban
probably wouldn't want to do it like you
get your your butt whipped by the
houston texans then all of a sudden
you're two weeks later your name's
attached to the usc job i mean
that would not be the way to to dip your
toe in the nfl pool
um
but obviously you can't get any better
of a name than that for college football
so is there any there there any smoke
with that i don't i don't think there is
i mean i like what i just said a bit ago
the the president didn't want to want
anything to do with urban meyer a couple
of years ago
um because of some you know what she
perceived as his baggage i think also
with this now like urban
just is he's a wildly unpredictable you
know person in this regard like he was
the guy who
who retired at florida and then came
back a day later and he was like like
there's a lot of
there's a lot of 180s that go on he
feels strongly incredibly so about
something one day and then an hour later
it can change or a day later it can
change
um you know if he is if he is owen nine
or one and eleven
i could it wouldn't surprise me if he
had man i don't need this the thing is
if you really wanted to be a college
head football coach at a very attractive
situation he absolutely could have been
the texas head coach last year the ad
there had come after um there was a lot
of talk they they really tried to reach
out to him
and at that point i think he's looking
at what was the big 12 and thinking man
i could if he wanted to i could go in
there and dominate this league
uh he he
you know i don't think the nil aspect
was it was something that was enticing
to him of the direction of college
football but again now that he's coming
off of an nfl experience maybe that
changes his perspective who knows i
don't think anybody knows to predict
where urban meyer's mind is going to be
for with much certainty a month from now
or two months from now especially if
you know like i mean the houston texans
no one thought they're going to be very
good and they just they just you know
throttled him in the opener if there's
going to be a two months of that who
knows what he's where his head's going
to be at
and then what about um the timing of
this bruce feldman because obviously usc
doesn't have to make a move right now i
mean why not sit back
wait
and choose any of the uh former nfl head
coaches going through the
uh nick saban career rehabilitation
program including the guy who preceded
james franklin in penn state in in bill
o'brien why not
no that that's a name that like you know
it comes up a little bit and you sit
there and think
with that name how how would that play
in los angeles how would it play in
recruiting he did a you know he did do a
good job terrifically changed ability to
penn state my god franklin who basically
took them took it to the next level
i don't know you know on one sense i
think
if usc because i'm sure he has he's
already had
you know an impressive start everybody
who's been the offensive coordinator at
alabama has been wildly successful so
you think you so you expect he will be
my guess is
if they end up with him as the head
coach and i'm this is i don't want this
to come out like i'm like he's not a
legit you know credible coach but if
they end up with him i i suspect there's
been some other people who either
turned it down weren't interested
or
they just didn't think they were a great
fit
you know like the fact that he he was
you know had some success as the head
coach of the houston texans
i you know and he has the bill bella
belichick you know stamp of approval and
now he's been with nick saban
you know that's all good i think it's
probably
you know relatively safe if you start
getting into like oh is it going to be
him or
you know pj fleck i mean i would guess
so well you know bill o'brien would
probably would probably play better in
terms of what usc's fan base would think
but i think if they get to that point i
think there would be a there'd be very
much a wait and see and
i don't want to say it'd be an
underwhelming hire because that's not
fair to say it that way but i just think
that right now
um
you know we'll see we'll see how much
interest they get it's usc but at the
same time usc has ended up with some
very
very
suspect uh hires since pete carroll left
so who knows what they're gonna end up
with yeah how much are they loving this
in the uh athletic department in
westwood right now bruce what do you
think yeah it's probably not a better
time to be a bruin because you know chip
kelly just beat
lsu and they kind of whipped them when
they did it and there's a lot of
enthusiasm excitement for where they're
at at this point um it's quite a 180 and
i think if you're
honestly if you're if you're
usc i don't know how you look at this
situation and go
yeah i wouldn't i would rather have what
they have compared to what we have you
know right now i'm talking i'm bruce i'm
talking hoops too i mean what are you
you know what i mean like
i'm talking hoops too
and i'm talking about what's going on in
in football with chip kelly and
you know there's a george you know the
jordan brand they've upgraded the
wasserman centers where like
you know a lot of nfl guys trained there
in the off season there's a lot of
really positive things that have
happened about like you know i honestly
at this point like ucla athletics has
become cool again
um because of the final four run and
certainly because of the buzz around the
football program after that win it was
one win not like it's been
you know it's not like
not it's not like it's been they just
won the pac-12 title but i think there's
a lot of enthusiasm around ucla in ways
that it hasn't been
for a long long time because even when
they were good with maurice jones drew
you had reggie bush across town yep you
know that's not the case right now like
ufc is a mess this isn't like oh yeah
mjd's and well there's maurice jones at
the time i guess and he was over there
going but you had usc and and what they
were doing now it's only ucla that has
some buzz
last one four years there were some
other hot seats beginning to to boil get
hotter in college football is there
enough at lsu that's a rough start for
ed o'giron i think he needs to uh he
needs to get the offense and the
offensive line going there's definitely
that i think there's a lot of
um i think there's a lot of frustration
now coming out of florida state with the
way they lost mike north i mean that was
just a debacle the ending of that at
jacksonville state i still think they
probably won't make a move this year and
give him a little more time but i think
patience is is where and thin i would
expect a lot of coaching changes to
happen this offseason it was a
relatively quiet year last year rich and
i think
right now especially when you've already
seen a few schools already moved uconn
has come open now obviously usc i think
there will be some bigger jobs i would
not be surprised nick rolovich has all
kinds of issues that he's dealing with
at washington state you know stemming
from you know what's going on with him
and the vaccine i think there's a lot of
places like that
that uh you're gonna see a shift who
knows you know arizona state has issues
with the ncaa but they're dealing with
herm is definitely i think
a guy who could be in trouble there as
well too
you know i'll just say this in in
parting you know i kind of brought it up
when when norvell was first hired at
florida state and i know it's a lot of
poo pooing about it
i think dion's the perfect guy there man
if that hot if that seat's hot look in
this day and age
reaching kids reaching kids in high
school reaching kids with a cool program
and a cool name wanting to play there
and and then showing off what you want
to do with your kids it does help to
have a coach you can call into stephen a
smith any time and then win some games
and the buzz that he brings to
you know uh the hbcu where he's coaching
in jackson state i'm telling you man i
mean
i think dion's proven
that he he can do this thing and i
understand it's not d1 and it's not
florida state but
i said it before and i think that's just
it's inevitable that that he would have
been the perfect tire and maybe a future
one i'll just throw that out there
look i mean i think the more time he
coaches there and the more
yeah i think the biggest challenge for
him is going to be to prove that
you know how stable is he going to be as
a head coach in terms of what i don't
think anybody wants there is to turn
into like kind of a sideshow
right so you've had a few things there
they're a little bit
you know they don't need that kind of
publicity but obviously the star factor
and his
his ability to be in people's homes yeah
and to get into recruits homes that is a
huge thing so i think if he surrounds
himself with a good staff and an
experienced staff it's going to be
interesting to see because certainly
there's there's pressure gonna mount on
mike dorvell after last weekend bruce
thanks for the call appreciate it let's
talk down the line um and um and and i
appreciate the two cents here today
thank you always a pleasure right back
at you bruce feldman
fox sports the athletic check out his
article he didn't name all the names
that are in the article check out his
article on the athletic
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here